ah the cool breeze and warm sands of end
sanity beach
wampa fruit daiquiri love one
crash panda coat wait there's no time
doctor neocortex and dr entropy are
causing havoc once again
and we're here to put a stop to it
an incredible 24 years have passed since
crash bandicoot burst onto the
playstation
and out of cortex's lab jumping
sprinting and
spinning his way across the island in
hopes of rescuing his bandicoot
companion
torna players immediately fell in love
with crash and his cast of wild and
wacky friends and foes
the brilliant humor and the precise
challenging platforming since then crash
went on to have no fewer than six
sequels in the main series
as well as a ton of spin-off titles
teaming up with some colorful characters
along the way
and now crash is back for the first
fully new game
in over a decade crash bandicoot 4 it's
about time
tasks our heroes with their biggest
challenge to date
dr neocortex and dr entropy have escaped
the interdimensional void they were
imprisoned in
at the end of crash bandicoot wart and
now they have plans
big plans multi-dimensional domination
plans
fortunately crash and his sister coco
are all limbed up
and ready to take them on
as a direct sequel to crash bandicoot
warped there'll be a lot that's familiar
to returning players and fans
who've been with the series since the
beginning at its heart crash bandicoot
has always been about the tense
platforming timing a jump falling to
your death
making a jump landing on spikes dodging
the spikes
and running straight into an enemy that
muscle memory building challenge is all
there but the game was expanded in so
many
ways to add depth scope and
replayability
the interdimensional setting completely
reimagines the landscape of crash
bandicoot
and this time around it opens up more
expansive levels
and huge vistas we've not seen before
just as fans of crash bandicoot warped
will have their favorite setting from 22
years ago
each of the dimensions you'll be
traveling through in crash bandicoot 4
it's about time
has its own unique theme and art style
and each with new mind-bending
platforming challenges to solve
fortunately you're not alone in this
adventure with a familiar
or maybe not so familiar face making
their playable debut
wait donna but you're
different fans will finally be able to
play as tawna
and not as they might remember her in
this dimension
toner is a toughened experienced
adventurer
complete with a colorful new look and a
handy new tool called the hook shot
allowing her to swing and grapple her
way around platforms and
enemies her adventures have also taught
her a neat trick in wall jumping
which sees her reaching platforms no
other characters can
but adds a whole new challenge when it
comes to nailing your platform
timing how many times have you beaten
this clown anyway
three really only three funny
seemed like more the hilarious story
beats of the crash bandicoot games have
delighted fans
for decades especially when it comes to
the devious and
over-ambitious plans of cortex and
entropy
players will be able to take control of
dr neocortex
as we see him trying to thwart crash and
coco through his own levels
running alongside those of our heroes
using his blaster
he can change mata and dash his way
through new obstacles that are going to
give
longtime fans a brand new challenge
he's not the only bad apple getting his
own levels either
dingodile has hung up his flamethrower
and villainous ways
in favor of running a diner but after
witnessing its destruction
and getting sucked into a new dimension
has found himself wrapped up in the
fight
not wanting to be left out crash and
coco are also treated to some new toys
of their own
changing up the way you tackle each
section a good old floaty mask pal aku
aku
is back and he's brought friends yes his
friends are
also masks these new quantum masks grant
brand new powers
allowing our heroes to control time
reverse gravity phase in and out parts
of the world
and supercharge their spins with dark
matter
not content with these new powers will
also be wall running
rope swinging and rail grinding through
levels adding a whole new level of depth
and thinking to the obstacles and
keeping that tense forward momentum to
the platforming
not a fan of crash's blue shorts firstly
what's wrong with you
but secondly you can play the game as
coco rather than crash if you want
as they're interchangeable for any of
their main sections in the game
but if it is just about the shorts then
crash has you covered
throughout the levels you'll be
collecting gems that unlock new
quirky outfits for our characters miss
the old leather jacket from warped
it's in there take on the futuristic
dimension dressed as a pirate
who wouldn't once you feel you've
mastered the levels there are brand new
challenges with inverted mode
that'll have you rethinking everything
you know about the levels
as a turbocharged take on mirror mode
you'll be repainting the world in front
of you
navigating your way underwater or even
running through an
overcranked old timing mode that plays
faster than the normal game
everything new and crash bandicoot 4
it's about time
is about building on what made the
original games on the playstation
so funny so challenging but also
so rewarding to complete whether you're
a longtime fan of crash's lovable if
confused face or you're looking at
trying out your first crash title
you'll find a platformer that'll have
you laughing as much as it'll have you
cursing at the obstacles and enemies
that lay within
you can get crash bandicoot 4 it's about
time when it launches on playstation 4
and xbox one
on october 2nd 2020 now where did i
leave those shorts
oh full of sand